it's great to welcome back to the
program lawrence krauss theoretical
physicist cosmologist professor of
physics and director of the origins
project at Arizona State University the
new book the greatest story ever told so
far this is sort of a story Lorentz as I
understand it and very often my
understanding of your books is limited
at best is sort of of how how we got as
human to our current level of
understanding of the universe is that by
mind the ballpark well you're in the
ballpark that's pretty general it's it's
a story of indeed how humanity and and
mostly focusing on the last of the more
recent times but it starts with Plato
unveiled the the illusion of reality
that we we all have when we look around
around us it's an amazing story of how
we have cut through that the the
nonsense and and buy a lot of red
herrings and and and
dead ends a lot of drama taking what is
I think the most exciting intellectual
journey that humans have ever taken to
understanding indeed how we got here and
have found that as part of it we were a
remarkable cosmic accident that at a
basic level the universe looks really
quite different than it does to us to me
in this room that I'm speaking to you in
right now at a fundamental level the
forces are different the nature of
particles are different the analogy that
I like to use which I've used in the
book is imagine yourself living on an
ice crystal on a window one of those
beautiful ice patterns and you're living
on one of those crystals pointing in a
certain direction if your civilization
grew up on that crystal then one
direction would be very special and
physicists would come up with the force
laws which would be different in that
direction than perpendicular to it and
religions would would come up with
reasons why God intended that direction
to be special and etc but it's really
just an accident of your circumstances
it turns out we have discovered
remarkably that we're here through an
accident of our circumstances because
some fields froze in the early history
of
the universe that changed everything and
made a universe which wouldn't have
allowed any life to exist at all - or
stars or planets or aliens or anything
to actually evolve into a universe that
allows us to be here it's a it is a
remarkable story and the great part
about it is the best part is that so far
part because the story gets better every
day it's not like that old greatest
story ever told
written 2,000 years ago by Iron H
peasants who didn't know the earth
orbited the Sun that never changes
because they knew the answers before
they asked the questions which means
they really didn't know much at all our
story changes because we keep learning
and we keep being surprised I want to
dig in a little bit to the use of the
word accident that you have life on
Earth is sometimes called an accident
and you used the term accident in
different ways that are similar to that
during our different conversations I
think it can be hard for people to wrap
their minds around what you really mean
by an accident in this particular
context okay can you maybe talk a little
more about that sure that's why I like
the analogy of the ice crystals because
you know they're there all over the
window in different directions right and
and and each one is there's nothing
especially significant about one
direction it was it caused it happened
that way because it's dust crystals or
something else that that caused one ice
crystal to form in this direction and
another to form in that direction and
there's nothing there's nothing special
there was no design in your window that
determined where the ice crystals would
point and and literally our existence is
as significant as one of the ice
crystals pointing in one direction as
opposed to the other a freeze of field
froze in the early universe had it
frozen differently which it could have
then we wouldn't be here to have this
discussion so the point is there's not
clearly it really is as much and let me
put another way in fact it's an example
that I use in the book and having you do
with what's called spontaneous
immigration if I balance the pants
pencil on my finger it's going to fall
and the direction that it falls is is
largely accident
so okay because I can't determine
precisely what how I'm going to lay it
on there so it'll fall in one direction
and so we're as much an accident as as
the direction in which that pencil Falls
it's an accident of our circumstances
it's not planned it's not designed it's
it's not it's not foreseen when the
initial universe was created all of that
there's no evidence that the universe is
designed for us and in fact even if it
looks like the universe is fine-tuned
for us well really what we're putting
that backwards what's really happening
is we're fine-tuned for the universe but
that story ism is an amazing one because
physicists didn't come to that because
that's what they wanted but literally
were dragged kicking and screaming
through lots of wrong turns to discover
this amazing picture we have the
standard model to describe three of the
four forces nature beautifully and in
fact that's another aspect of the story
that I think is so neat when people
think of the 20th century they often
think of that period 1905 to 1925 as the
golden era with relativity and quantum
mechanics were developed but there was
another 20 year period between 1955 and
1975 which is up to now unheralded which
may be viewed by future historians is
even more dramatic because we started
that era in understanding one force in
nature electromagnetism by the end of
that era we understood three of the four
forces in nature and moreover the
fundamental mathematical symmetries that
seemed to guide all the forces in nature
it was a an amazing period of
productivity and then based in that
theoretical picture which was bold and
audacious and could have been wrong we
spent 50 years building the most complex
machine humans have ever built something
I like to call the Gothic cathedral the
21st century the Large Hadron Collider
to test these strange ideas that could
have been wrong and we found out we're
right it's yet at the same time of those
discoveries were made we've also got a
whole new set of questions and that's
why the story gets better all the time
because we'll continue to learn and be
surprised anyway that's the brief sort
of summary of what I need by accident
and Andrea
the significance of this story which is
so much better than the story that
humans come up with because the
imagination of nature which guides us is
much better than the imagination of
humans well as far as the story that
humans sometimes come up with one of the
more difficult aspects for many people
about learning more about the history of
humanity our planet solar system the
universe the history of time is that the
more we learn the more we seem to
realize that the universe is sort of
indifferent to human needs and what
would be positive or negative influences
on the survival of humanity possibly
even even hostility actually to the
survival of humanity do you find also in
the talks that you do that this is a
difficult thing for people to reckon
with well I think it is difficult at
some level initially I try and
anticipate it did by by pointing out
early on that that the fact that the
universe doesn't care about us
doesn't doesn't make our lives less
precious in fact I think it's a much
humbler approaches it's the ultimate if
you wish the ultimate installous ism to
assume somehow that without the unit
without us the universe it is perfectly
it has no meaning and a moreover that
the universe was designed for us the
universe will go on existing whether
we're there or not and for and that may
seem depressing but instead I think we
should do it at our existence as its
precious accident that we should take
advantage of it is truly amazing that
things configure themselves so that we
can survive and evolve and I should
you're actually right the universe is
not only in different jobs in most part
in a great sense it's trying to kill us
with every every turn it's amazing we
that light gutters and survive for 4
billion years but it has and we have
evolved the consciousness and we can
appreciate the Wonder and awe of the
universe and it makes our existence more
precious we can make our own purpose and
use our brains to not only enjoy the
universe that we live in but to make our
own experience better and the experience
of our children's children even better
than that I think it's a hopeful view
not a depressing one let's pick it up
there we've been speaking with Lawrence
Krauss the new book of course is the
greatest story ever told
so far the so far a key aspect of what
we're talking about here we will take a
break there and pick it up with him
tomorrow
we're continuing the conversation we
started yesterday with theoretical
physicists and cosmologists Lawrence
Krauss the new book is the greatest
story ever told so far and one of the
interviews I read that you did around
this interview you sort of drew a
distinction in terms of why questions
and how questions and you were critical
in one sense of religion not because it
necessarily gets why questions wrong
which I'm sure you probably believe
based on our past conversation but
because you think that the why questions
are less useful to us than the how
questions let's start there why do you
think that it's not there that's useful
they're usually less well defined in
fact often they're meaningless because
when you ask a why question it presumes
purpose why are we here well it presumes
that there's some purpose for us to be
here what if there's no purpose I would
argue that almost all the time when we
say why we really mean now you know why
is the sky blue it's not you know we
don't think there's a purpose for that
but we can explain why that's happened
we know why why why do I have to breathe
to survive all of those things and so
those why questions that really are why
questions often presume purpose that's
what Y means and those may have no
significance whatsoever at all for
example if there is no purpose to the
universe and then the Y part of why are
we here is literally meaningless well
wouldn't it be meaningful in the sense
that to the individual whatever the
answer is and maybe the answer is we
don't know why or there is no reason why
it still seems like it would be very
meaningful to individuals living their
lives on the planet what you're right
but I guess I guess for many people
should be answered the why point why are
we here saying there is no reason is not
may not seem that satisfying but we can
nevertheless say okay there is no reason
why we're here but that doesn't mean
that your life has no purpose you if you
ask why you know why am i doing what I'm
doing or or why is the world the way it
is we can talk about humanity because we
have
we have intends and we have
consciousness and so extracting that
from the universe doesn't mean that as I
say our own life doesn't have purpose
and meaning but I think we have to we
have to accept that the answer to the
question why are we here could be as
I've argued in fact likely is that it's
an accident there's no there's no
fundamental existential reason why we
happen to live on earth and are here to
enjoy or not enjoy our lives and and and
to survive as a species or not survive
as a species there's no there's no no
one is in control but us are you I'm
kind of think of how to phrase this
question are you in thinking about the
human exploration of both the how and
why questions are you concerned with the
increased seeming malleability of what
we know of as truth facts and reality
that's happening because of the
political situation in the United States
I think I'm I think I'm sort of getting
getting through the the core question
here what's your view of how science and
epistemology and so many of these issues
are increasingly being treated by the
political establishment that's in power
well that's a real problem and that's
why I think my story which is a you know
effort someone esoteric is about the
forefronts of what we know and it felt
takes readers hats from from their
personal experience out to that edge and
I think it's a fascinating story but it
has a moral that science the process of
science can overcome the biases and
prejudices of individual scientists to
cut through the illusions and that same
process is essential for the proper
functioning of a democracy one of the
real problems is we've used science as a
set of facts because often it's been
taught in school that way that's not
what it is it's a process for deriving
facts it's a process for telling sense
from nonsense by skeptical inquiry the
use of empirical data and many sources
to check it and testing ideas after you
have them all of those things are an
essential part
of what we should be doing in the public
arena how we should be forming public
policy and how the public should be
examining and judging their leaders so I
think it stands in some sense from us
from an educational system which was
based on a time when school was was just
a bunch of facts but now I can get you
know I have my my phone here I can get
more information on my phone that I
could get in any school but I get more
information and what we have to do is
train people to to be their own filters
and right now we don't do that well
enough and I think I think the lesson of
science is that we can use that
scientific method and we need to use
that scientific method not to use
science to decide how to how to live but
to use science as a tool to make public
policy more rational and to allow voters
in some sense to become more informed
it's a huge problem right now and the
only way to tell that I can see to tell
the information from the misinformation
on the Internet
is to have that filter and starting to
have that filter is something that
people it's difficult to develop late in
life and we need to we need to sort of
input it into our educational system
more effectively and that means teaching
science not just the sign jig method but
teaching science is more questioning and
answering asking good questions is a key
part of it and not knowing always the
answer you said earlier maybe is it okay
to say we don't know and is that
acceptable and of course it's acceptable
we should be willing to say we don't
know I'll call the universe works at all
levels we don't know the answers more
parents more teachers should be willing
to say that but accompany that by saying
let's figure out how we might find out
and make it a journey and often a joyous
journey to discover the truth do you
think that it's possible that the reason
that sometimes certain aspects of
certain scientific questions become so
politicized and and there's a fear
around what what science may tell us
would be that there are some who believe
that once we have the scientific
consensus on a particular issue that it
definitively presumes what public policy
should be and I guess to
put a specific example to it maybe the
reason that we see climate signs
skepticism to the degree that we do is
that there are some climate skeptics who
assume that if we agree that humans are
having an impact on our climate that the
political repercussions of that are
definite when in reality having the
science should just be the starting
point you can still have a debate over
what the policy should be I don't know
it seems like maybe this is an aspect of
what's going on crash you've answered
exactly what I would say science doesn't
make the policy look you can decide ok
humans are affecting climate but you
know what for this reason or that reason
is political or economic reason we feel
we can't deal with it that's that's
accept that's policy I would hope it's
not acceptable policy but that's to be
debated but you can't have a rational
debate about what the policy should be
answer you accept the reality that these
changes are happening and then you can
say look we have more urgent needs at
home we can't afford this to invest in
in in energy sources which will make it
much more sustainable in the long run
and in fact then have the discussion of
what of what the cost-benefit analysis
is of investing in those things now
versus later but you can't even get to
that important second stage of policy
making without the first recognition
that that that this is a reality and
reality you know as my favorite one of
my favorite science fiction writers Phil
K dicks at once said reality is that
which continues to just even when you
stop believing in it and I think we have
to recognize that you're not allowed you
are allowed to invent your own realities
and apparently win elections but in the
long in the long run reality comes back
and bites you in the butt well what's
the I mean I think there are obvious
ways that when you win an election and
you invent your own reality you know
this could be scrubbing scientific
climate data that's been collected over
decades or requiring approval before new
data can be released on certain subjects
by government agencies as we've seen
there's a sort of obvious and noticeable
ways that a political apparatus
can create a reality but what are some
of the may be less visible ways in which
this anti science perspective can be
dangerous that the average person might
not hear about in the news well I think
I think one of the more dangerous ways
is to propagate inaccuracies and
continue to propagate them with impunity
first of all secondly is to attract the
educational system which in some sense
you're seeing happening so that so that
the kind of rigorous thinking and
skeptical analysis that we should be
training students to do is missing and
and and the other is reducing funding in
general for the kind of programs that
that are essential for us to get the
kind of data we need to to make sense of
policies you know heralding going to
Mars spending enough twenty billion
dollars to send a bunch of people to
prancer on Mars but not mentioning the
fact that you're going to kill NASA's
earth sucks all the program that studies
the evolution of climate on earth which
is so essential for also protecting us
from storms that sort of thing cutting
and in fact I just wrote a piece about
this cutting look the current budget
cost nine hundred million dollars from
from the agency that is the dominant
agency supporting physical science
research in this country that's 20% of
the budget it's responsible for all of
the stuff I talked about in the greatest
story ever told so far cutting that
cutting the National Endowment for the
Arts the National Endowment for the
Humanities
the Corporation for Public Broadcasting
and the Institute for museums and
libraries yet all that up that's one
point six billion dollars at the same
time the budget adds two billion dollars
as a down payment on a wall and you've
got to ask yourself the question which
is better for the health and future of
the nation killing science and culture
and those those things that get people
thinking about the world around them to
defend us from a potential but largely
non-existent immigrant hoard as I love
to say using the quote from the
physicist Robert W Wilson was
first director of the Fermi National
Accelerator Laboratory he was asked by
Congress will that building that aid in
the defense of the nation but it should
know but it'll help keep the nation
worth defending and I think if we look
at these attacks on science and culture
we're seeing effectively an
administration that is disempowering the
public from being able to effectively
and rationally control their future
we've been speaking partially at least
about the new book by Lawrence Krauss
the greatest story ever told so far it's
always so great to have you on thank you
well it's great and I don't mind that we
make we made the segue because these
understandings of the universe at the
forefront of the process by which we get
there does have have important
implications for understanding ourselves
in everyday life and that's why I think
that you were connected that's why I
hope people will also look at the book
reached in both problems